hello party people it does not sound
right when I say it it's a Spencer line
yeah I think of my own yeah my own this
is honest trailer commentaries the show
about a show that talks about other
shows we hope you've watched the show
that that shows talking about and then
you watch that show so that then you can
now watch this show where we go deep her
on that show yes and it's thoughts on
the show yes this week Batman the
Animated Series is series I'm so excited
for this yeah by the way is on vacation
yes we let him go for a much-deserved
much reserved earned vacation his
thoughts are in the trailer they always
are yeah this was super fun I it's cut
the many people may ask why it's coming
out of blu-ray which is really just the
flimsiest of excuses to just do this
yeah it was a little nerve-wracking to
do right after Doctor Who well yeah
there was a time where I was sort of
tackling both simultaneously and you had
not slept really fun to jump between the
two you know it's a very ponderous
British sci-fi and then yeah nineties
ponderous animated programming I was
surprised and I guess the I'll fold this
into my overall thoughts about the
series I was surprised at how because I
was pretty like we're gonna do another
series like right out okay and then as
soon as I started watching Batman like I
started clipping through and I was
really enjoying it didn't feel like I
was wearing who's gonna feel like a huge
chore after whoo yeah and oh man it was
just it's a really good show yeah and
for people that are curious and we for
purposes of this trailer if you go into
the Canon of Batman the Animated Series
there are 47 different ways to determine
yes what is Batman the Animated Series
what we what we tackled for this trailer
was there was a first season of 65
episodes mhm and then after that they
produced more episodes yeah
some of them were labeled as Batman the
Animated Series some of them were
labeled the new adventures of Batman and
Robin
and then you had other
that were a different animation style
that we're sort of like what who
actively labeled Batman the Animated
Series yeah so that that second round it
was just Batman and Robin right was that
second round which I think there might
be some some that were still that it
still looked like Batman the intimate
series there's a mixed animation style
so there's some people just like why
didn't you talk about Mad Love or why
don't you talk about a bullet for bullet
a for Bullock or why did you talk about
this it's because it was in that weird
like we had to figure out where we're
gonna draw the line yeah I think we all
do this very seriously I think this very
seriously these are the kind of
discussions we have we're like if we
want to be curious we did we're going to
the 65 that we're really gonna burrow
down into cuz that was the heart of the
series was you know that first season
not to say that there weren't a lot of
great episodes after that there were but
you know even visually like once you
start mixing in in one trailer once you
excuse me once you start mixing new
adventures of Batman and Robin visually
it all looks weird mashed up together
because it looks like a very different
show there might be one or two shots in
this trailer I think that got mixed in
yeah I think there's a scarecrow shot
the Scarecrow shot in there it happens
but I think largely where we were coming
from was that base of like those first
65 which are just pretty untouchable
pretty yeah and I mean that's sure every
day after school I remember this is a
huge deal this was landed in a post
Batman Returns pre Batman Forever yep
really kind of the height of the bat
mania yeah and also Fox Kids Club was
coming into its own yeah and after
watching cartoons after school was
really like starting to give Saturday
morning cartoons kind of a run for their
money x-men was ruling Saturday's Batman
was on in the daytime yeah and then you
actually helped me remember this because
I was make I was like no no guys x-men
was part of that block but you helped me
remember the Phoenix saga was like a big
special yes event yes
and then next men went back to
Saturday's we start I need tunes
Animaniacs Animaniacs those are everyday
cartoons yeah what did your kids club
have local teen hosts that hosted it my
dad briefly I think it
the very dawn of it and then it went all
yeah yeah mine was like I think her name
was Kelly and then Gill Gill stir no
guilt it was like hey kids
Gill Gill stir here and you can win a
chance to see me and Kel like at the
Louisville Science Museum like come on
out yeah now back to tiny to reminds me
if they had there was a there was a
there's the Nickelodeon Kids Choice for
a while was stick stick Lee gulsta
reference a probably definitely he'll
stick today would watch old videos of
like the cat came back together yes yeah
okay you want to jump into those jump
into this don't you ever want us to say
about Batman and Robin and Joker and we
have a controversial Joker tape we do in
this one we'll get there for the money
by the way Kevin Connor before he was
swole before he was existentially
depressed and before he was a cartoon
never leave the cave without him he was
a swole existentially depressed literal
cartoon in some tortured Oh Batman
the animated series returned to a time
when pop culture was an oversaturated
with superheroes after school and
dial-up internet give us a few precious
minutes offline so we extended bus yeah
it's because there's a key noise that
makes me laugh that that's the funniest
part of the modem sound to me I have
attendance
[Music]
and there's a time with kevin conroy
iconic Bruce Wayne and industrialists
with the money of Tony Stark and the
fashion sense of Dwight Schrute us but
well very good his lawyers to mow a
thunder bolt out of the blue thunder
bolt the beginning of the series I was
looking at Bruce Wayne and I was like I
was like yellow and brown like what a
weird combination like who would wear a
suit as I watched the office like anyone
who has Netflix constantly yeah
it's just in a constant cycle we we
finished it we just go back to the
beginning and I the only person I'd seen
other than cartoon Bruce Wayne wearing a
yellow shirt at a brown suit was droit
root I want to think that they did that
on the office on purpose that he has a
kid Dwight was like that's how a man
dresses beats
yeah Battlestar Gallactica Batman
animated series fingers crossed that
that's what they did before he got his
assistant bares it was bad maddening I
mean oh yeah also the nostalgia of that
modem noise yeah for people that the
younger generation you know having to
get off the internet so you could make
or receive a phone call I remember
trying to get online like after my
parents have gone to sleep and just like
quiet there's no hiding it or the joy of
picking up the receiver they're just
here yeah all right you'll never know
Katie White's goat but when night falls
this punch of Holly will become the
Batman night falls
pause detect night when night falls
night falls is inserted very very
purposely very purposely into this
honest trailer as a nod to a classic
movie fights moment or Kristian harloff
fold us all by making up a movie called
night falls starring Al Pacino and
Robert Iger
find any information about it yeah he
almost hood weakness but yes night falls
if anybody's wondering that is in there
specifically as a reference to Kristian
harloff Snite Falls continued give who's
also the world's greatest ninja
this was fun collect his jacket Batman
I've accessed Gotham's electrical
mainframe there's another computer
uplink to this one I'm tracing the link
now greatest magician I love the three
button keyboards and the greatest
ventriloquist when I studied with Zatara
the magician he taught me about
ventriloquism Wow this family does a lot
but does he dance
I didn't Adam West oh yeah the King this
is we couldn't think of a button for
this and we didn't have your name over
the great punch thing to really but this
game isn't crusading solo or TV has a
whole cake full of allies like Alfred
Pennyworth Butler a Batman but king of
sick burns slave faces losing his
integrity
one of my favorite moments in quite a
while
yeah I didn't well not in the version of
the script that I did a draft on and I
think that wasn't actually written into
this no that's Kevin and TJ yeah it
there's something to be said for when
you do these for long enough where
everyone sort of gets on the same page
and is able to sort of have a shorthand
back and forth and the fact that like
post can take a script and start editing
and literally pitch their own jokes like
edit is is really awesome because yeah
that's what I pay for it is that is a
100% credit to Kevin and TJ fir'd for
that one I the first time I saw that I
left my ass off I think that's move on
Robin the Boy Wonder as in boy I wonder
what's good about between the show and
Titans
Batgirl a college kid whose relationship
with bats is super creepy after using
The Killing Joke movie Barbara come in
you've grown now yes we know that
probably technically The Killing Joke
and Batman animated series don't exist
in the same universe same creative team
if I'm not mistaken right same creative
team behind both I think definitely was
sane voice actor for at least for Conroy
and so still a pretty similar Canon like
yes she's not exactly
they're not exactly both forty yeah I
know I just remember watched an episode
is the first the thing--the is the first
time you see barbara gordon and bruce
amuses like barbara you yeah so yes we
know that technically but you know it's
it's still it's a joke why'd you guys do
that yeah why because it was gross
sexist and commissioner gordon a humble
civil servant missus gonna watch by a
billionaire psychopath so originally
before we watch this i because we were
working on Doctor Who
mmm-hmm I had started trying to get
ahead just putting the end of the string
outs myself and one of them was Batman
does this a lot
he will ghost he will what we don't get
in is when he ghosts people which is
basically you're talking to him and you
look up and he's disappeared like man
but the other thing is he just pops up
out of nowhere and huh scares people and
as Myers said like Mike yes like Michael
Myers and Mike Myers both very sneaky if
I had a nickel if I had a nickel for
every time Mike Myers snuck up on me
Rockets but when we put the string outs
together I noticed how much he just its
tormented Commissioner Gordon it's
mostly Gordon it's mostly Commissioner
Gordon yeah why just be like hey just
yeah Jim but back here at some point you
have the conversation with the guy where
you're like I get it you can sneak in
and out that's great you can also just
call me at this point home you don't
have to have like I appreciate the
mystique I don't need to be a part of it
yeah you
a little anybody home little knock on
the windows sale you know you don't have
to just emerge from the shadow put a
little wind chime that my young daughter
Barbara made at summer camp out by the
window you can jingle that you know her
sometime or when you knew her in
elementary school you creep gross
alright let's watch Batman torturing
permission is a knife own call no no
you're a ninja you don't have to keep
proving it to Grandpa Cobb alright
together they'll protect Gotham a city
trapped somewhere between 1932 and 1992
a town we have to climb is up the nights
are long and the people are rectangles
that is that's all you that is a style
choice that I noticed that is one of my
favorite jokes in an honest trailer
there are some people driving more
rectangular than most yes which I love
the style of the show it's not ripping
on it it's just a lot of it is how they
draw men's suits yeah cuz they're in the
very classic kind of double breasted
stuff all of the men's suits are drawn
with like a squared off yeah bottom and
then a straight side it's so like even
Bruce Batman himself is kind of tapered
but Bruce Wayne is a it's very much a
rectangle and ever you know everybody's
all the designs are so simplify that
it's all just like polygons of some sort
with clothes thrown on them anyway but
yeah just but the crime is high the
nights are hot the people are rectangles
sometimes you just notice that but they
want a rectangle men around goals
it's a city under siege for the best
rogues gallery in animation history
featuring character defining portrayals
of toupees you're talking to
this is every bitter freeze this
brilliant yes Harley Quinn do people
know that Harley Quinn was introduced to
Batman the Animated Series I mean I'm
sure Batman fans do yeah Batman fans I'm
sure do I guess we could have pointed it
out a little better in this maybe but is
literally the character-defining yeah I
think we point out that originally the
draft had that it was it was the
introduction but it's something just
easier to just say Harley Quinn because
that is the defining I mean that is that
is the portrayal that still is her this
is uh I yeah I think it's the show that
made her an IV sort of an inseparable
pair yeah there's a great episode with
Harley naívi yes is the two of them on
the lam yeah and the comics ran with
that and I think we're getting a movie
the animated series flavored Batman to
this day as far as how it portrayed Mr
Freeze I don't think had that whole Nora
fries backstory and like that was really
cemented by the show yeah the idea I
think and if it if it wasn't the con cuz
I can't I can't remember if it was in
the comics like that performance and
that style like that's that's different
yeah and though here comes our here
comes the controversy the best Joker
ever yeah I said it I think it is bat
menagerie he Possible's he he is every
hits every beat of it equally the
homicidal maniac part the anarchy the
chaos the fun funny the jokes the quips
the gag like everything about the Joker
and I think that goes to every character
in the show every aspect of the
character that's been delved into over
the years for Batman for the Joker is I
think all represented extraordinarily
well oh yeah I mean look this is the
show that gave him again a sentient
clown robot that did his bidding on that
garbage barge that's true yeah
captain clown Mark Hamill speaking of
lightning bolt moments I cannot tell you
how how it was one of the shocks of my
young life when I learned that Luke
Skywalker did the voice of the Joker
yeah I do not contemplate a city where
that was way later could that be true
that can't be true that's not possible
yeah that's yeah yeah I wasn't um
growing up as a nerd I wasn't like as
much as a I need to know what's inside
of this and makes it tick like I just
watch stuff and enjoyed it and I didn't
realize it was Mark Hamill it's a way
way later well the the voice actors if
you watch the end credits for a Batman
show the voice actors fly by criminally
they gotta get to power the talent that
they had yeah like some of the great
then there's Richard Moll doing to face
and they had Mark Hamill that John
Vernon who was an animal house he was a
recurring voice they they had I think
Roddy McDowall doing the Mad Hatter they
had like dance of like really good
people but those credits would flop
those credits would fly guys we gotta
get ya cuz Power Rangers is already
starting exactly yeah
so yeah the day that I figured learned
that the Joker and Luke Skywalker the
same person I think this story is he
reached out because he wanted to be
involved in the show he did like a
one-off character maybe and it was like
that because he'd been on flash he did
he was the trick the trickster on flash
and they were I think they had a joker
and then he didn't work out and so
Hamill went in to read for it and I was
reading like one of those oral histories
of the show and they were just watching
him in there and they're like oh god
yeah that's it I mean the respect to
Luke Skywalker I know people love Luke
Skywalker but man it was the Joker that
might be my favorite oh he's amazing his
the Joker and mask of the phantasm is so
awesome oh so Deary great lines yeah
yeah it's just a good Joker it's a great
joke a really really good Joker not
taking away from the other Joker's but
some of them yeah but not too good
little ya go donut
and a bad menageries worth of animals
it's another fun thing to know that
you're watching all the standards like
you can gasp and punch you know like you
can gasp a snake I guess that's less
yeah
stick to something less threatening I
don't know penguins weird oh here it is
a bad one pause pause this is from an
episode called I've got Batman in my
basement yes I believe even the creators
of the show have acknowledged is the
worst that works on Batman the enemy
series there's very little Batman in it
mhm and the penguin is as you can see
apprehended by two children it's very
exciting you know what I won I see
people argue for worst and I think
they're dumb for it you know the episode
were Bruce gets amnesia and goes to jail
and he like fights that mob boss in jail
there's like no Batman in the episode
until like right at the very angry he's
undercover no he's undercover II like
straight up can't remember who he is
oh it happened a couple of times then oh
there's one where he's the homeless guy
there's what it's like that he gets
knocked out in the camera who he is I
mean that might be the mob boss is like
always eating a turkey leg yeah that guy
yeah that's a great episode I see that
on a lot of lists of like there's no
definitive Batman in this episode it's
like what okay it's still good that's
that's a favorite of mine but yeah you
got a really good rogues gallery and man
penguin jizz penguin got the shortest
penguin did not did not Dana did you
know was the far superior yeah yeah oh
boy yeah he sucked in this show yeah he
wasn't great blowing up so bite of the
bat-signal and revisit the highs
[Music]
I am that night
[Applause]
and the Lowe's you've made her Maude
psychic it--there's reaction with an
actual cab the darkest adaptation of
Batman ever made literally the darkest
because they drew it on black paper that
wasn't afraid to hit kids with complex
philosophy Santayana says that those who
forget the past are condemned to repeat
it then break it up with a guy kicking a
werewolf in the face fight you're
looking for try starting one with me see
see that's only want a definitive
portrait of a beloved character that
balances multiple tones across dozens of
hours that can only happen with a
perfect creative teen and lands at the
perfect time in the cultural zeitgeist
is that so hard
amazing work from Robert all blade that
killed a scratch incredible that was a
little bit of I feel like this is a
standard that people hold Batman to and
there were so many things that had to go
right yes to actually work and they all
went right and that's very rare this is
an x-men somehow happened at the same
time even both went as right as they
could go there's something to I love
when you start reading about like the
making of the show how it just seemed
like this thing that was never going to
get off the ground and like you read the
the oral history and they're like oh god
they're gonna let us do this we got to
put together a team now yeah and they're
literally like walking around two
buddies over at Tiny Toons like hey
we're making a Batman card you will come
make a Batman cartoon and so it's like
just that that team assembling and yeah
it's it's the lightning striking and
right place at the right time for all of
these people and I I don't understand
how they I mean props of the Fox
executives because I don't understand
how because they made like a short that
was a literal I think it was just a
fight scene yeah a fight scene and
considering that the two things that
were that were major from Batman was
still Adam West and and today burden
Burton had just come out but those were
more like weird yeah and they had
already gotten the pushback of
kid-friendly companies McDonald's and
stuff yeah Batman Returns ooh yeah this
didn't come out up to bat the first
that movie just came out after yeah
Batman Returns which had been sort of
like a lot of people it's like that this
is too dark yeah and they do an actual
dark man crazy it's crazy and probably
the the creators over at UH x-men the
animated series have said the same thing
of really like sung a lot of praises to
the executives at that time for yeah
well because the Fox was yeah and
literally nothing to lose yeah I've
never done this before exactly yeah
already hygiene related insults listen
up scum wad here's a horse have a great
back and forth alright scum bucket scum
bucket get her trash working in any way
professor crane lost his appetite and
sneaking up on people but also in Tehran
permission Griego is a great episode
marksmanship should have been dead many
times over
[Music]
like Maui shooting at pause laughter to
be fair I have I have shot an ak-47 yes
and it is hard to hit anything with an
ak-47 but this guy's not even that man's
not even there man
like look at him yeah sometimes like
he's just shooting it I feel like if I
was that close I could it yeah just
don't shoot yeah at that point just him
with the gun you know where he is
yeah just run over and whop him in the
face and you know where he is run over
and shoot into the elevator
yeah guys nari sorry maniacal laughter
this is just a cartoon show I love to
have the bad guys take the load clocking
the only one in the world who like
hockey
that means Oh faced with ugly eyes kept
trying jackass attacks so the row is
non-lethal ways to incapacitate penises
there were some standard yeah explode
the otter
so fires and explosions were frequently
in obviously up but more than I remember
ya know every episode gotta Susan was
flammable city on the face and planet
we're sitting on a powder keg and Batmen
thumbs up da Jeff no it's a different
Batman forever but that's a callback on
this Batman Forever okay we need to talk
about the intro verses all crooks are
just two guys who happen to be walking
past the bank at night then when the
entrance explodes they run away like any
sane person talking well he summarizes
going around blowing up banks and Batman
doesn't know who did it either he had to
drive there but does that stop him from
beating the crap out of him and leaving
him for the cops without any evidence to
convict him on this is why
Alandise are a bad idea you guys yeah so
that lever it's only Spencer had that
that stream of thought and then he
summarized it for the tag and we were
just like no dude yeah because I've
never thought about that but it's a way
there's no evidence whatsoever tying
those two to the car yeah but this is so
this is one of my favorite moments that
happens working here because Spencer and
I sit our backs are to each other and
you you know that like he's thought of
something that like is really good when
you get this so how do we know those
guys robbed the bank
just like dives into it yeah we're
getting a so from Spencer yeah I know
this funny the shows are good you get a
silver and Spencer that means he's like
a bloodhound strapping in
like a bloodhound that's caught the
scent yeah I'm just gonna let him off
the leash and just go boy yeah in this
case I yeah there was a much shorter
version and we were like no no no no
yeah you know let's live with this
so in Spencer rift like a jazz musician
yeah I learned that like voila it's kind
of it's like and it's just so special
says I carry says do we have any deleted
scenes extras I am vengeance we tie him
the night
I am the 90s underrated Series feel it
scars are in it for kids
sadly dead parents hmm you're sure
there's no one you want to call first
friends family husband maybe smooth bats
considering how easily everything in
this city catches fire maybe a fleet of
police blimps was a bad idea
I love the Gotham fleet of police
dirigibles now so much did you did did
not that have to be changed because John
cursed you for writing the word
dirigible into the script he was not
happy put the word dirigible in the
script yeah what actually so so many
props to John that last run about oh we
want his millions of hours in blur blur
the original end section also mentioned
launching the DC Animated universe yes
and so the rant was something like sooo
DC that's how we won just millions about
was a bubble but we've poured over as a
childhood that do this and this and this
and this and this and it was just this
one long run-on sentence yeah and like
and we definitely used it
hey takes into it John was just like I'm
going to kill you it was like edge
alright let's fix it he's like no I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get any did he
nailed it it was mine you wrote the
whole thing yeah yeah but you nailed it
buddy yeah he nailed it it doesn't mean
he didn't nail it but I am putting the
word dirigible into every surgery so
that's Batman Joe that is Batman great
show this is a great show you know
obviously not without its it's lows but
what over over what 65 65 episodes well
again it depends on how you count a lot
of people count it to 85 or more
depends on where you stop and start the
cycle and out of that I think there were
like four that I could do without yeah
they were very few that I was just like
every one of them had they were
entertaining
yeah I love the title cards like the
yeah the art deco land of yeah
yeah the show was really well done so
yeah yeah it's just so good it launched
Justice League and hyperman that was the
cool thing about by a Torme Oh spider
blood spider blood radioactive spider
blood keep asking us to do that I don't
think as well as they yeah wait that's
CG intro that was bad yeah it was not
good that's a weird song too
it's really weird yeah and you know
obviously things have to change and
evolve at some point but for the longest
time the fact that these designs sort of
like unified all the DC animation
visually it was such a cool feet like
that that was awesome
yeah no great show it's a classic it is
a classic and you should see it if you
have it you absolutely should watch it
that's it that's the show now that
Batman's got in a blu-ray where's that
x-men we need that x-men animated series
owns it who owns that Fox
I'm guessing Fox owns that Marvel yeah I
guess Mart Disney now whoever owns it
blu-ray yeah remastered I saw some
screenshots from the Batman remastering
it's oh my god it looked cool yeah give
me that ax men give us that ax man and
we will give you a clue for next week's
honest I think we might stay animated
Jill she might even stay in this genre
okay but jump back over to the feature
side that sounds great yeah that's all
we're gonna give them yep see you guys
next week
you
[Music]